bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
Catherine Vautrin bonsoir et merci
d'être là vous êtes la présidente du
Grand Reims dont vous êtes l'adjointe au
maire Reims c'est 43% de logement
sociaux et un bilan très lourd de
destruction durant ces nuits des mutes
on va en parler longuement vous êtes
aussi la présidente de l'enrue l'Agence
nationale de la rénovation urbaine qui
fête ses 20 ans alors qu'est-ce qui a
été fait et qu'est-ce qui reste à faire
pour dégainer nos quartiers on va en
parler donc moi tout à l'heure dans la
deuxième partie mais on commence ce soir
par cette question comment réconcilier
la police avec les jeunes des banlieues
au terme de ces nuits d'émeutes des
voies s'élèvent dans l'opposition mais
pas seulement pour appeler à une refonte
complète de l'institution policière ce
soir Gérald Darmanin ne ferme pas la
porte à une réforme alors comment très
concrètement travaille les policiers sur
le terrain dans les quartiers quels sont
leurs relations avec la population il y
a t-il une
haine anti-flic grand débat dans un
instant avec mes invités avant de
retrouver nos parties pris nos
affranchis et puis Bourbon Express bien
sûr l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
voilà pour le menu on y va Catherine
Vautrin
[Musique]
y aura-t-il un avant et un après la mort
de Naëlle dans la police leur est
évidemment à la réponse pénale au fait
de délinquance qui ont explosé dans
toute la France et au retour à l'ordre
mais la question du lien police
population dans les quartiers se pose
aussi plus que jamais la rupture
est-elle totale entre ces jeunes et la
police alors si la police je cite doit
se réformer elle ne doit pas servir de
bouc émissaire c'est ce qu'a dit au
Sénat cet après-midi le ministre de
l'Intérieur bonsoir Éric Polliat merci
d'être là vous êtes députés renaissance
de Gironde vous suivez les questions de
sécurité tous ces textes liés à la
justice et à la sécurité à l'Assemblée
nationale vous débattez ce soir avec
Hugo bernalicis bonsoir député la France
insoumise du Nord vous aussi vous suivez
tous ces textes police justice et
notamment une réforme en cours de
discussion à l'Assemblée bonsoir
Abdoulaye Kanté merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes policier dans les
Hauts-de-Seine engagées sur ce fameux
dialogue police population va y revenir
longuement vous êtes auteur de policiers
enfants de la République chez Fayard
enfin bonsoir Michael Kors ravi de vous
accueillir vous êtes journaliste à La
Croix vous avez beaucoup enquêté sur la
police notamment au commissariat de
Roubaix vous avez passé un an en
immersion au central reportage publié au
long cours dans votre quotidien qui est
devenu un livre Le Central chez Bayard
Catherine votre évidemment votre lecture
de ces événements nous intéresse reste
Reims n'a pas été épargné vous nous
direz si on parle encore sur le terrain
entre ces jeunes et ses policiers ou si
la rupture est totale on commence par
planter le décor la fracture jeune
policier c'est le chrono de la peau pour
commencer
bonsoir chère Stéphane je me retourne
pour vous accueillir je vous invite à
faire la même chose bonsoir
donc gagarres de doute si on doit partir
d'un point de départ c'est que en ce
moment il y a une fracture entre les
jeux de la police pour dire ça je
m'appuie sur un sondage de cette semaine
de l'Ifop vous voyez qui montre que dans
l'ensemble des Français ont plutôt une
confiance et sympathie dans la police
mais sauf que quand on demande aux
jeunes donc les 18 24 ans ben c'est plus
du tout le cas il y a une chute
carrément de 20 points sur les
sentiments positifs qu'on peut qu'ils
peuvent éprouver vis-à-vis de la police
donc il y a une vraie défiance des
jeunes envers la police donc d'où vient
cette fracture bon en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il y a deux accusations
dans le débat public qui sont souvent
adressées à la police c'est le racisme
et les violences policières donc quand
on parle du racisme il y a une étude qui
fait référence elle date de 2017 elle
avait été commandée par le rapporteur
des droits qui étaient Jacques Toubon
donc Défenseur des droits Défenseur des
droits d'ailleurs c'est marqué il
suffisait de le lire ce que je n'ai pas
fait déjà que tout bon donc pas vraiment
à gauchiste et qui disait que quand on
est jeune noir ou arabe en France on a
20 fois plus de chances de se faire
contrôler le risque de se faire
contrôler par la police donc ça c'était
il y a 5 ans je sais pas si les choses
vont vraiment abolé dans le bon sens
quand on voit la violence du communiqué
des deux syndicats majoritaires dans la
police donc vu que les propos
caractéristiques sont interdit on a
l'impression qu'on joue un peu avec les
limites de la loi pour qualifier les
métiers de hors de sauvage ou carrément
de
nuisible donc finalement quand on voit
ça on est pas tellement étonné que l'ONU
épingle la France vous avez vu que le
Commissariat au droit de l'homme parle
profond problème de racisme dans la
police française et on n'est pas non
plus étonné que de l'autre côté le
préfet de police de Paris soit choqué
par les accusations de l'ONU en écoute
là pour le coup monsieur Duhamel assez
choqué par l'utilisation de ce terrain
assez choqué voilà donc il n'y a pas de
racine dans la police on lutte contre
des délinquants qui mettent en vie et
qui mettent en danger pardon la vie
d'autrui et on continuera à le faire et
on continuera le faire donc ce que dites
c'est que la police n'arrête jamais des
gens en fonction de leur couleur de peau
mais uniquement parce que ce sont des
délinquants et donc les chiffres qu'ils
cite à l'appui sont les chiffres la
préfecture évidemment qui nous disaient
que vous voyez 48% des délinquants
arêtes à Paris sont des étrangers voire
70% dans le cas des vols avec violence
donc on en arrive à la question est-ce
que si on contrôle plus souvent ceux qui
ont l'air d'être étrangers c'est du
pragmatisme ou du racisme attention je
ne réponds pas rien que le débat battra
son plein tout à l'heure et puis pour ce
qui est des violences policières c'est
Marine tondeier donc la patronne des
verres qui tirait le signal d'alarme en
disant attention on va vers une
américanisation de la police peut-être
en pensant notamment à l'affaire Georges
Floyd bon en fait on en est quand même
très très loin vous voyez ça c'est le
magazine basta donc un magazine
d'extrême gauche on va dire qui publie
des chiffres en disant 39 personnes fait
par la police en 2022 aux États-Unis
c'était l'an dernier plus de 1000
personnes tuées par la police donc
carrément 30 fois plus donc cela dit
c'est peut-être pas la bonne comparaison
faudrait peut-être revenir à des
comparaisons européennes et c'est ce
qu'a fait Mathilde de panneaux hier en
comparant bien la police allemande et la
police française dans le cas des refus
d'obtempérer on l'écoute
comment un jeune de 17 ans peut-il être
tué par un policier en République
française pourquoi 16 personnes
ont-elles trouvé la mort depuis un an et
demi en France pour refus d'obtempérer
quand l'Allemagne n'en compte qu'un mort
en disant alors effectivement les
chiffres là sont assez accablants pour
les méthodes de la police française il y
a peut-être une petite objection qu'on
peut faire en tout cas rappeler que le
nombre de refus d'obtempérer a augmenté
de 50% au cours des 10 dernières années
donc 27000 refus d'obtempérer l'an
dernier ce qui statistiquement vraiment
augmentent les risques de dérapage mais
en fait quand on accuse la police d'être
à l'origine et d'être la source des
violences et des tensions en banlieue il
y a quand même un argument qui empêche
le raisonnement c'est quand on regarde
que du côté des pompiers et bien au
cours des 15 dernières années le nombre
de pompiers agressés n'a cessé
d'augmenter hors on ne voit pas comment
on accuserait les pompiers d'être
responsable des violences dont ils sont
les objets donc évidemment il y a sans
doute des réformes à faire dans la
police je crois personne du contraire
est-ce peut tout refaire de la cave au
grenier comme le dit certains et ben
vous vous êtes là pour en débattre merci
beaucoup Stéphane j'ai commencé avec
vous Abdoulaye Kanté dans quel état sont
les policiers vous étiez sur le terrain
il y a eu plusieurs nuits d'émeutes on
imagine un énorme épuisement bien
évidemment après déjà toutes les crises
affrontées mais ce qui a pas un peu
désarroi aussi face à cette fracture
avec les jeunes on a traversé une
période qui est assez difficile je pense
que pour ceux qui ont connu 2005 ça a
été quelque chose de très inédit on va
dire la violence qui a explosé comme ça
d'un coup c'est vrai qu'on était pas du
tout préparé mais je pense aussi que du
côté de nos collègues il y avait aussi
une forme de résilience parce que
effectivement voilà il y a eu un drame
personne ne le nid je pense que aucun
policier ne se satisfait de la mort d'un
jeune homme d'un jeune notamment du
jeuneel même aussi on va dire celui qui
a tiré mais pour autant je pense que oui
l'état de actuellement dans la tête des
policiers c'est il y a eu un vraiment un
déchaînement de violence parce que ça
s'est ça a dépassé tout ce qu'on pouvait
au-delà même de comment dire de du
pillage etc il y a aussi des cibles des
policiers on a été ciblés que ça soit à
la fois sur le terrain mais aussi dans
nos vies privées c'est à dire que vous
avez les policiers aussi qui ont été
menacés j'en fais partie aussi et c'est
vrai que là c'était un déchaînement de
violence mais pour autant il y a une
femelle à Marseille notamment donc il y
a eu cela beaucoup de violence c'est
également mais il y a eu aussi
tous ces comment dire ces forces qui ont
quand même et on peut pas déplorer aussi
on va dire de mort on fait parce que ça
a été quelque chose de très très vite
complet avec les jeunes si on met voilà
il y a les émeutes mais il y a aussi une
difficulté pour la police notamment
nationale sur le terrain on dit que même
parfois le la rupture est totale il y a
plus de discussion possible vous le
constatez comment vous l'expliquez ça
dépend en fait vous savez que quand il y
a une émotion qui par exemple à certains
faits divers forcément évidemment on
peut pas discuter avec eux quand on est
sous le coup de l'émotion moi si vous
voulez je j'a beaucoup sur le dialogue
parce que avant la répression il y a une
forme de dialogue et quand moi je vais
dans ces quartiers là discuter avec ces
gamins je peux vous dire que le mot
police tout de suite il y a énormément
d'interrogations des fois aussi
peut-être une forme de réticence mais
quand on leur parle déjà il faut savoir
écouter vous savez moi ce que je fais en
général et je le dis aussi à mes
collègues je dis que vous savez pour
être compris il faut expliquer vos
actions si vous n'expliquez pas vous
êtes incompris et ça donne beaucoup
d'inepties et je pense que il faut
accentuer sur cela il faut commencer par
cela pour déjà expliquer ce que l'on
fait pour être compris et ça forcément
c'est un gros travail mais la police ne
pourra pas tout est-ce qu'il y a une
haine anti flic Mickaël corps sur le
terrain là où ça a pété pour le dire
simplement je sais pas en tout cas le
mot n renvoie à la question des émotions
et je pense que c'est la bonne question
la gestion des émotions d'un côté comme
de l'autre c'est à dire que
gérer ses émotions ça s'apprend et côté
policier on entend beaucoup parler de la
formation initiale
elle est trop courte etc etc
moi ce que j'ai observé sur le terrain
c'est que les policiers une sorte
d'école souvent ils sont pas si mal
formés par contre il y en a d'autres qui
sont là depuis beaucoup plus longtemps
je pense qu'un policier ça doit se
recycler comme un Pilo de d'avion voilà
parce que en fait c'est un métier qui
est dont on mesure pas la technicité la
technicité en matière judiciaire mais
aussi dans l'emploi d'armes et de plus
en plus d'armes dans l'emploi de
véhicules etc etc on
va venir sur les solutions possibles la
formation c'est un mot qui a été
prononcé
plusieurs le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
était auditionné au Sénat mais sur le le
communiqué d'alliance alliance une ça
c'est important vous avez parlé entre
collègues vous avez parlé à des
policiers depuis est-ce que vous
reconnaissez dans ces mots qui sont
quand même d'une violence ordre sauvage
nuisibles guerre est-ce que les
policiers avec qui vous avez des
contacts se sentent solidaires de ces
mots là ou pas moi les policiers que
j'ai pu avoir ces derniers jours ils
étaient pas du tout dans ce genre de
narratif c'est vrai que c'est des
narratifs alors auxquels alliances nous
habitue mais généralement on est quand
même plutôt habitué à trouver ces
mots-là du côté de policiers en colère
et policiers en colère aux élections
professionnelles ça fait 3% après sur le
syndicalisme policier et Alliance il y a
des stratégies sur les dernières
élections présidentielles on pourrait y
passer l'émission mais en gros il y a
une stratégie un peu de rupture
et qui marche c'est à dire que il y a
des syndicalistes de police qui des
syndicats de police qui en affichant
comme ça de manière extrêmement
politique et bien une adhésion totale
sans aucune nuance à ce que vivent les
policiers et bien en fait qui récoltent
de l'adhésion et ça c'est un fait après
moi les policiers que j'ai eu ces
derniers jours ils étaient dans des
questions encore une fois plus
techniques et plus simple c'est-à-dire
par exemple on leur dit bon dans les
deux premiers revenu on leur avait dit
peu d'armes de force intermédiaires et
là on leur a dit maintenant vous
interpellez mais en fait c'est comme
c'est tout le temps comme ça dans la
police on le rappelle on l'aura pas dit
comment ça allait se faire exactement ça
veut dire que dans les commissariats là
l'obsession c'était comment on décale 15
ou 20 officiers de police judiciaire
parce que c'est pas le tout de ramener
des gars dans des jaunes qui sont déjà
pleines et qui explosent après il faut
quand même des gens pour faire de la
pâte de la doctrine de la gestion des
effectifs que vous posez on va pas du
tout jeter le propre sur toute une
profession c'est pas l'objet de ce débat
mais est-ce qu'il faut pour vous
monsieur le député quand même
s'interroger sur la police après la mort
de Naël est-ce que vous dites sur le
fond déjà
il faut ouvrir la boîte à réforme je
crois que c'est un débat avant tout qui
mérite qu'on n'aille pas dans des trop
grandes généralités trop facilement
quand on parle des jeunes il y a pas les
jeunes il y a des jeunes qui faut
différencier etc et on l'a vu même si
les jeunes effectivement en rapport de
confiance avec la police compliquée
c'est pas tous les jeunes qui détestent
la police donc il faut quand même quand
on des jeunes les 18-24 ans on arrive à
un jeune sur deux qui a confiance
seulement et là on n'est pas sur des
statistiques de jeunes qui vivent dans
les quartiers c'est national donc c'est
dire et le face-à-face que redoutait
Gérard Collomb on dit dans les quartiers
entre les jeunes et la police
c'est quoi c'est un des visages de la
République c'est un des visages de ce
qui fait sens de ce qui représente un
petit peu nos institutions et c'est
souvent le dernier qui reste dans
certains territoires en plus à changer
et donc forcément des choses à changer
mais je pense que moi je suis pas contre
le fait de d'englober une réforme de la
police dans une logique plus globale
dans une réponse plus globale que la
République doit faire à la jeunesse à
notre jeunesse à lui redonner des
perspectives à lui redonner à un espoir
et notamment dans ces quartiers là plus
encore ou dans la ruralité parce qu'on a
aussi une perte de confiance dans nos
institutions dans la réalité mais je
pense que c'est une réponse globale et
stigmatisée que le problème deviendrait
ne viendrait uniquement que de la police
est une erreur voilà toutes les
précautions mais on a voilà
décliné différentes problématiques soit
après soit et cette question de la
police elle se pose inexcusable ça va de
soi tout ce qui s'est passé les
violences Hugo bernalistes vous voulez
condamner je savais pas que c'était le
sujet de l'émission et ensuite j'arrive
à l'émission d'organisation policière
non mais je vous pose la question
forcément mais oui je vous dise que je
ne suis contre le fait qu'on brûler une
mairie je suis contre le fait qu'on
voulait je suis contre le fait qu'on
voulait une salle le spectacle une
bibliothèque je peux faire la liste
parce qu'après en face ils vont
m'expliquer que j'ai pas fait la liste
entière qu'on peut brûler le reste hein
parce qu'on est dans cet ambiance donc
vous les condames quelle vive aussi les
les policiers
de polémiquer comme d'habitude comme
votre président de deux groupes a fait
plus tard
la mort de ce jeune kaporal-chef des
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris voilà donc on
est habitué votre regard sur l'action de
la police dans les quartiers est-ce
qu'elle a évolué elle ce qu'elle a été
durcie elle a évolué comment vous
expliquer quelle rupture 2005 c'est un
point de rupture notamment aussi dans
les méthodes qui sont employées dans les
dans les quartiers populaires et c'est à
partir de là où on a commencé à avoir
l'apparition des flash-ball puis des LBD
dans les quartiers populaires qui
n'étaient pas utilisés avant et des
méthodes de contrôle social qui sont
beaucoup plus avancées et ça fait suite
à une décision politique parce que là on
est en train de parler politiquement
comment tout ça a évolué et comment on
peut y répondre la fin de la police de
proximité avec la décision de Nicolas
Sarkozy a conduit à avoir une difficulté
en 2005 justement des suites de ça il
faudrait remettre des gens dans les
quartiers sauf que remettre des gens des
policiers en l'occurrence dans les
quartiers et pas que je pense mais à
tout le monde des policiers c'est de
quelle manière or la doctrine qui a été
élaborée par Nicolas Sarkozy qui était
en rupture avec la police de proximité
ça s'appelait et c'était d'assumer à
l'époque la police de projection on va
mutualiser les moyens sont des grands
hôtels de police et vous allez appeler
le 17 etc et on va vous envoyer des
véhicules ce qui fait qu'on perd
l'ancrage territorial l'ancrage
géographique du policier et donc vous
retrouvez avec des équipages
indifférenciés qui peuvent intervenir
dans le même quartier y compris à tour
de rôle sans cueillez de coordination et
dont et surtout une police qui vient en
ayant pas la capacité de faire ce
qu'elle dit Monsieur Kanté tout à
l'heure à quelques jeux partage il y a
pas d'explication si vous avez il y a
une appel 17 on arrive on interpelle on
fait ce qu'on a à faire on s'en va faire
l'histoire et sur un rendement comme
celui-là compliqué que ça on va dire que
si projection
si vous voulez qu'on secoue président
à ne pas couper la parole mais je veux
juste pouvoir aller au bout de ce propos
donc c'est une question de doctrine et
d'organisation on nous a fait miroiter
avec la police de sécurité du quotidien
qu'on allait reprendre pied dans les
quartiers bon mais des guillemets à la
formule d'ailleurs avec les quartiers de
la conquête républicaine bon bilan on
est en 2020 la sécurité bilan par
glorieux d'ailleurs où est passé la
police de sécurité du quotidien vous
savez qu'à l'époque la troisième fois
que je pose la question à Gérald
Darmanin au directeur général de la
police on nous avait promis de faire une
enquête sur une analyse universitaire
sur la police de sécurité du quotidien
et vous retrouverez les visuels sur les
réseaux sociaux sur le site du ministère
s'appelait le Lab psq avec des
universités
personne n'est au courant si elle existe
encore personne ne s'interroge plus de
rien des dispositifs comme ça au fur et
à mesure et là on est dans la réforme de
la départementalisation de la police
parce que des réformes il y en a plein
dans la police en réalité beaucoup le
rapport de l'inspection montrait qu'il y
avait 7 ou 8 réformes en cours en
parallèle en ce moment au sein de la
police nationale donc la question c'est
pas escale doit être réformée pas les
c'est quelle direction politique quels
sont les objectifs qu'on assigne à la
police les jeunes mais je voudrais votre
regard je l'ai dit il y a eu un incendie
de tramway il y a eu énormément de
saccages à Reims il se parle sur le
terrain ces jeunes là ou le divorce est
consommé et cette police de proximité
vous manque-t-elle en tant que je ne
vais pas faire évidemment l'inventaire
de ce qui s'est passé à Reims mais c'est
vrai que c'est une ville qui n'a pas
cette habitude et que très concrètement
jeudi soir puisque c'est passé
essentiellement jeudi soir il y a eu
dans l'ensemble des quartiers je
rappelle cette quartier politique de la
ville et vraiment quatre quartiers dans
lesquels les émeutes ont démarré au même
moment avec effectivement des risques y
compris pour la population quand on
prend un tramway dans lequel il y a du
monde et qu'on met le feu très
concrètement on a une volonté qui est
une volonté de blesser il faut dire les
choses moi ce qui m'a beaucoup étonné
dans ces émeutes ça a été également le
fait que quand on va s'attaquer au
bureau de police dans les quartiers les
premières victimes sont les habitants
c'est pas le sujet je reviens sur le
sujet police et moi très concrètement et
aucun d'entre nous n’était né ou en tout
cas aux responsabilités moi je pense
qu'on est arrivé à une étape qui est une
évolution de la société une évolution
par rapport notamment à l'autorité et
j'imagine que celles et ceux qui étaient
avant nous
dans les immédiatement après 68 ont dû
se poser des questions parce que là
aussi il y a eu un certain nombre de
réflexions autour de l'autorité le la
société
a évolué les choses ont bougé relisez le
général de Gaulle discours de 69 et vous
verrez que très concrètement il y a
l'étude des propositions la France a
évolué et est-ce que finalement depuis
maintenant depuis 2005 vous citiez les
émeutes de 2005 est-ce que finalement
depuis 2005 il n'y a pas eu une
accumulation de recherche de réponses
sans avoir une approche globale qui a
effectivement fait prendre conscience
que quand on parle de la cohésion d'une
société sur quoi sommes-nous d'accord et
rien qu'à vous entendre parler on voit
bien qu'il y a certains noms de sujets
sur lesquels nous n'avons pas la même
lecture et le rapport à l'autorité a
changé et quelque part cette notion de
rapport à l'autorité est une notion
vis-à-vis de la police dernier point il
y a un élément qu'aucun d'entre vous n'a
évoqué c'est que depuis les
collectivités et notamment les villes je
parle des villes parce que c'est souvent
là il y a les quartiers ça veut pas dire
qu'il n'y ait pas de sujet en rural mais
souvent dans les communes il y a
maintenant dans les villes des polices
municipales et il faut aussi qu'on
regarde quel est ce rôle entre police
municipale d'un côté police nationale de
l'autre et d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'on
confie aux collectivités comment
responsable alors on y va sur les
solutions police municipale police du
quotidien la question des armes est
posée la question de la doctrine de
l'organisation mais d'abord on va les
entendre les jeunes m'a été vraiment
étalées
son micro dans le 19e arrondissement de
Paris micro ouvert visage couvert
reportage
mes affaires
à même le sol pour pour aucun prétexte
et à la fin du contrôle bah merci au
revoir et il me laisse repartir
président la façon de mettre la pression
sur quelqu'un qui n'est pas forcément
habitué à se faire contrôler ou quelque
chose comme ça donc à partir de là moi
ça crée une certaine peur moi je vous
dis la vérité moi la relation que j'ai
avec la police c'est que je les évite il
y avait les affrontements entre les
jeunes et les policiers il y avait une
personne qui passait
pour rentrer chez lui juste derrière les
policiers et il y a deux policiers qui
se sont qui lui ont dit de partir et le
monsieur il a dit oui je vais partir et
il y a des policiers qui l'ont attrapé
qui l'ont tapé certains
qui savent que si il reste
ils vont rentrer avec des coca ils vont
entrer avec des choses
il y a pas de policiers
c'est ils sont là pour faire régner les
lois et
de respecter un petit peu tout le monde
comme tout le monde doit les respecter
je pense premier truc à avoir par
exemple dans le contrôle de routine
c'est
[Musique]
un policier de la politesse
tout simplement bonjour monsieur
de la formation de la bonne et je pense
j'essayerai de donner la parole aux
jeunes
il faut que si j'utilise soit faite et
surtout que à un moment donné la police
reconnaisse que il y a du racisme dans
la police c'est ça qui ils ont du mal à
reconnaître il va falloir que la police
fasse un très gros effort
mais vraiment un faut qu'il faut qu'il
tombe la main
qui doivent s'occuper de ça et ça aide
de trouver des solutions
dans la police chez certains policiers
bien sûr c'est que ce sont les mêmes
questions qui reviennent chaque fois
quand je vais rencontrer ces jeunes dans
les quartiers difficiles ce sont
toujours les mêmes à me sortir
évidemment le racisme dans la police les
violences illégitimes vous avez vu je
dis pas violence policière parce que
voilà
donc ce sont des je pense qu'il faut
avoir aussi ses capacités aussi d'écoute
parce que c'est vrai que si on veut
expliquer nos actions il faut savoir
aussi écouter les critiques nous sommes
un service public et je pense que c'est
que ces jeunes aussi ne connaissent pas
forcément leurs droits moi souvent quand
je vais les voir je leur dis écoutez
souvent quand vous allez faire un
policier qui se comporte mal envers vous
est-ce que vous savez ce que vous faites
c'est vous avez raconté l'histoire mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait après c'est
comme Paris pour le racisme moi j'ai
jamais nié qui avait une minorité de
racistes dans la police effectivement et
je peux vous dire que les nouvelles
générations ont le dénonce il faut être
malhonnête à dire que oui que la police
française est raciste ce qui dit ça
franchement c'est du malhonnêteté mais
sans nom effectivement
pourquoi pas en formation initiale je
vous apporte une solution pourquoi pas
en formation initiale essayez d'associer
les le monde associatif c'est-à-dire des
jeunes de quartier venir en formation
initiale et se dire bah écoutez voilà
les futurs politiques vous allez avoir
en face de vous et voilà nous ce qu'on
attend de vous voilà comment le contact
peut se faire c'est peut-être quelque
chose d'assez on va dire innovant mais
pourquoi pas parce que c'est de là que
ça commencera donc il faut revoir la
formation les interlocuteurs une mise à
jour en Allemagne la formation dure 36
mois
combien de temps elle dure tiens vous
savez en France 12 mois et depuis peu 12
mois et ça a augmenté mais comment on
explique ça Éric
simplement que voilà il y a eu une
période où c'était passé à huit mois
mais les fins initiales non moi j'en
fais partie on a toujours fait 12 mois
12 mois qui s'accompagne à la sortie
d'école d'une année stagiaire donc nous
étudie en formation continue mais ça a
compté l'histoire non mais les
stagialisations c'est pas une année de
formation ah mais écoutez on vient dire
à celui qui arrive dans l'école on t'a
pris ça ici ça se passe comme ça toute
notre fonction publique vous savez très
bien que ce qui se passe à l'école on
essaye effectivement de se rapprocher
plus de terrain je pense que excusez-moi
avec tout le respect que je vous donne
vous avez été à l'école et c'est vrai
que tout ce que vous avez à l'école de
police de Roubaix très bien alors donc
voilà vous avez été à l'école forcément
on essaie de se rapprocher de la réalité
et forcément la réalité est tout autre
que ce que vous apprenez réellement vous
essayez de vous rapprocher on va dire de
ce que vous avez appris donc c'est ça la
réalité maintenant comment faire pour
essayer de faire en sorte que lors des
actions des policiers qu'on puisse être
on va dire professionnel essayez de
faire en sorte que derrière que toute
action parce que comme l'a dit Madame
Vautrin la société évolue la société
devient de plus en plus violente et je
pense qu'on a tous une responsabilité
donc et maintenant comment faire une
question d'autorité à restaurer et ça
s'apprend aussi vous êtes prêt à ouvrir
ce chantier là de la formation notamment
à tout le moins alors la fonction
publique elle est construite comme ça en
France en fait son école on est recruté
et après on a un an de stagiarisation
c'est à dire pendant un an on est tué
sur le terrain il y a pas on n'est pas
un stagiaire ISO automatiquement il y a
des gens qui sont qui sont recalés à la
fin de l'année de stage donc on arrive à
bien deux ans de formation que comme
ailleurs donc il faut quand même le
repréciser et deuxièmement je pense que
quand même principalement à mon année de
stagialisation en tant qu'attaché
d’administration c'était à l'Irak
c'était pendant l'école c'était
titulaire à la sortie oui parce que
c'est il y a des exceptions
administrations
publiques d'État uniquement mais tout ça
pour dire que il y a la question de la
formation mais il y a aussi la question
de l'éducation de ces jeunes de
l'éducation plus globalement de la
société à l'appréhension de nos
institutions de ce qu'est un policier de
ce que représente la police et donc
c'est une double entrée une forme de
policiers c'est éduquer les gens aussi à
connaître la police on essaye de voir
sur la police vous avez vu un d'entre
eux a dit on doit être respecté mais
nous aussi on doit respecter et ça c'est
un vrai et ça c'est un vrai sujet alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer Gérald
Darmanin a évoqué quelques pistes et
puis je vous redonne la parole juste
après Michael Kors
alors est-ce qu'un policier peut
commettre des erreurs oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a à améliorer la
formation sans aucun doute d'ailleurs
nous avons posé quatre pattes plus la
proposition va sur une plus vous l'avez
voté je vous en remercie faut-il faire
davantage sans doute sans doute faut-il
mieux sélectionner les policiers très
certainement je veux dire que oui on
doit améliorer sans cesse et ce sera un
travail jamais terminé le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes sans aucun
doute je suis le premier à ne pas
accepter à son instinct qu'on tutoie les
personnes
c'est inacceptable
le tutoiement c'est cosmétique Michael
Kors ou c'est un vrai sujet non c'est un
vrai sujet après le vrai sujet je trouve
que c'est aussi qu'est-ce qu'on leur
demande aux policiers c'est-à-dire que
là dans le débat on se verse d'une sorte
d'illusion qui est de faire advenir un
nouveau jeune vertueux par l'École etc
et puis un nouveau policier vertueux par
la formation et on vivrait dans un monde
où tout se réformable en fait la police
moderne depuis qu'elle a été créée au
18e siècle elle a été créée pour une
seule chose c'est de gérer les marges et
de faire et de faire en sorte qu'elle ne
déborde pas trop et le terrain
prédilection de cette police là c'est la
rue et il y a des choix politiques qui
sont faits de quels sont les priorités
et on voit bien aujourd'hui dans les
chiffres notamment décrochage de la
jeunesse moi je vois aussi un
questionnement de ces priorités
politiques je pense que parmi ces jeunes
qui aujourd'hui critiquent fortement la
police il y a trois choses il y a trois
types de jeunes il y a des jeunes qui
sont hypersensibles à la question des
discriminations avec cette question
est-ce qu'elles ont augmenté ou est-ce
qu'ils ont de plus en plus sensibles
alors ça se mesure mais en tout cas de
son vrai deuxièmement des jeunes dans
les contextes de manifestation qui ne
supportent plus notre manière de
maintenir l'ordre et où sont là les
grandes questions de communication de
dialogues qu'on nous a promis et la
dernière chose c'est sur les violences
faites aux femmes la police a été
questionnée à raison et à tort sur sa
capacité à gérer les violences faites
aux femmes je dis à tort parce que là on
touche aussi des questions d'effectif
tout à l'heure on parlait de la police
de proximité mais la BAC qui arrive
motorisé dans des quartiers versus la
police d'avant qui est qui maillait le
territoire c'est aussi la différence
entre deux modèles économiques faut
savoir quand même que les dernières
grandes baisses d'effectif en France
c'est sous Nicolas Sarkozy parce que
comme me le dit un policier la droite
quand on est en période électorale nous
dit et bien on aime la police c'est la
danse nuptiale et quand ils arrivent au
pouvoir ils se souviennent que nous
sommes des fonctionnaires et du coup ils
en veulent moins et en fait une police
qui est plus motorisée qui est moins
pédestre qui maille moins le territoire
et qui est plus armé tout simplement une
police avec moins d'effectifs et les
effectifs c'est aussi des effectifs et
bien sur les questions de Jud à Roubaix
quand je suis arrivé il y avait 10
personnes qui travaillaient sur les
violences faites aux femmes 10 personnes
à la fin de l'année il y en avait trois
qui étaient partis en burn-out et elle
travaillait sur 100 affaires par tête
c'est à dire que derrière Marion 24 ans
policière qui bosse au violence
conjugales il y a une armoire en fer
avec 100 dossiers de femmes qui
potentiellement sont victimes de
violence ça c'est sa réalité donc la
question c'est comment définit les
priorités qu'est-ce qu'on leur demande
et comment on met aussi la police en
partenariat là imaginer que la police va
à elle seule en tant qu'institution avec
ses petits bras et ses nouvelles
formations gérer la question de
problématique globale dans certains
quartiers
nationale pour réformer ou pas
l'urgence l'urgence c'est intéressant
parce que il y a la question des moyens
mais il y a la question des effectifs
mais c'est pas simplement des effectifs
il y a aussi les missions de terrain
l'urgence pour vous Hugo bernaliste si
on estime que par exemple en France et
bien le contrôle le contrôle par exemple
est beaucoup trop sensible et fait
porter sur certains individus et bien un
soupçon de discrimination c'est pas au
policiers sur le terrain et de vertueux
et à moins ou plus tutoyer c'est à
l'Assemblée nationale de voter et
d'interdire les contrôles les anglais
l'ont fait ils ont aussi fait d'autres
choix et je vous répondrai s'il fallait
vraiment lister les deux trois priorités
à vos yeux on parle beaucoup aussi de
l'IGPN jugée partie est-ce que ça compte
ou pas ça si on changeait
la formation initiale et la formation
continue de ce qu'on attendait policiers
je suis pour qu'on passe un minimum à 2
ans de formation initiale avant d'aller
en poser un ange
derrière ensuite je rappelle que c'est
Pierre Jacques il a fait passer un an
qui nous avait mis dans le dans le haut
du panier de la formation des policiers
le retour de la proximité avec la police
évidemment et puis un changement de
doctrine je veux une politique et d'une
police qui soit moins armée que ce soit
dans les quartiers ou que ce soit en
compliqué
vous savez que cette semaine pourquoi on
a déployé le raid et le GIGN c'est que
forcément on avait des individus
qui s'est pris quand même du 9 mm euh
j'ai vu le raid j'ai vu le oui vous avez
une manifestation il y avait zéro anime
les policiers jusqu'à présent vous
attendez parce que je peux pas finir une
présentation
ça veut dire que ça veut dire qu'il y
aura plus de policiers morts parce que
en fait vous avez des gens qui sont
armés donc dans les quartiers évidemment
le sujet on ne peut pas le nier mais
vous vous croyez que c'est le policier
de terrain qui va lutter contre le
trafic d'armes et le trafic dessus
c'est un métier ça s'appelle la police
judiciaire avec des effectifs
là et la dernière fois
c'est juste irresponsable moi je pense
qu'on vous mettra pas d'accord
ils sont victimes de leur succès ils ont
tellement de plainte qu'ils arrivent
plus à tout gérer mais ils ont fait un
organisme indépendant dans lequel il y a
des policiers pour donner leur avis
évidemment mais où les policiers ne pas
majoritaire et ça fonctionne
j'ai bien compris que sur la question
des armes il y aura pas d'accord sur la
question d'igpm partout c'est très
important est-ce qu'on est capable
d'avoir un organisme indépendant
disciplinaire dans la police c'est ce
que vous le souhaitez et ce sera le mot
de la fin les policiers sont extrêmement
contrôlés il faut arrêter de dire que
ils font n'importe quoi ils sont
extrêmement contrôlés c'est
l'administration la plus contrôlée de
notre pays donc moi ce que je veux
surtout c'est donc on touche pas les GPS
la police récupère un peu tous les mots
de la société également donc travaillons
aussi les questions d'éducation
travailler aussi les questions de
rénovation urbaine
elle est pas stigmatisée et à critiquer
la police sans vouloir la désormais en
disant qu'elle tue et qu'elle est
raciste pourtant le ministre a dit que
une réforme était possible donc on va se
revoir il faut il faut une réforme la
question on s'arrête là merci beaucoup
vous restez avec moi Catherine Vautrin à
bientôt goût analyse c'est dans une
dizaine de minutes on va retrouver
le parti pris de nos affranchis ce soir
EF chez elle va s'interroger sur les
conséquences de ses émeutes sur les JO
de Paris 2024 faut-il s'inquiéter Thomas
l'estavel nous alertes sur le bilan en
trompe l'oeil sur le télétravail et puis
dans Bourbon Express ce soir de quoi
parle-t-on Stéphanie Depierre on parle
des insoumis qui sont sous le feu croisé
des critiques de la part de leurs alliés
du gouvernement mais d'abord on va
plonger dans le bilan de l'enrure vous
pilotez donc l'Agence nationale de la
révolation urbaine qui fait 20 ans
qu'est-ce qui a été fait qu'est-ce qui
reste à faire en tout cas ça fait 20 ans
qu'elle a été créée on voit cela dans
l'invitation signée Marion Becker et on
en parle en Sainte Catherine votre
injuste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite Catherine Vautrin
c'est pour avoir votre regard sur la
politique de la ville à la lumière des
émeutes urbaines après la mort de Naël
comment transformer ses quartiers
comment éviter la ghettoïsation et
favoriser la mixité car Catherine
Vautrin vous êtes présidente de l'enrue
l'Agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine vous en avez assez de ce qui
estiment que trop de moyens ont été
donnés à ces quartiers aujourd'hui en
France il y a à peu près 5 millions
d'habitants qui habitent dans les
quartiers d'hippolytiques de la ville
dans le budget de la Nation ça
représente 500 millions d'euros pour
reprendre des chiffres à peu près ronds
ça veut dire que concrètement nous
parlons de 8 euros par mois par habitant
peut-être qu'on arrête de raconter que
il y a des monceaux d'argent public oui
il y a de l'argent public mais d'un
autre côté on a un revenu médian dans
ces quartiers de 13000 euros par an
13000 euros par an votre parole est
précieuse car vous êtes aussi une élue
de terrain engagée à 20 ans en politique
au RPR vous avez été conseillère
municipal de Reims député présidente du
Grand Reims mais surtout ministre auprès
de Jean-Louis Borloo le père de la
rénovation urbaine d'abord ministre
délégué à l'intégration et à l'égalité
des chances puis à la cohésion sociale
concitoyens vous étiez aux côtés de
Jean-Louis Borloo lors de la création de
l'enrue en 2003 dont vous avez pris la
tête en 2022 l'objectif de la rue c'est
de transformer les quartiers en
profondeur
reconstruire mais aussi des enclavés et
favoriser la mixité sociale tout
simplement en finir avec les ghettos
alors on a une question pour vous
Catherine Vautrin la politique de la
ville a-t-elle échoué dans sa mission
réponse à la lumière de ce que on vient
de vivre si je pensais qu'il n'y avait
plus rien je pense que je ne serai pas
là pour échanger avec vous la vraie
difficulté c'est de se dire que
incontestablement nous avons 5 millions
d'habitants qui habitent dans des
quartiers que nous sommes partis de très
loin parce que vous faisiez allusion à
la création de leur rue la loi aura
effectivement 20 ans le premier août et
à l'époque le constat c'était l'état de
délabrement dans lequel était les
quartiers vous reprenez le discours de
Jacques Chirac à 3 sur la force d'une
nation c'est sa cohésion son moteur
c'est l'égalité des chances et c'était
rien d'autre que la déclinaison du
discours de sa première campagne
électorale qui était la première prise
de conscience c'est indéniable que
beaucoup a été fait certains quartiers
ont même changé de visage les barres
d'immeubles sont tombés et il y a même
maintenant des transports pour les
désenclavés et en même temps c'est
toujours les mêmes populations il y a
pas de mixité sociale dans ces endroits
là et ça c'est qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché pourquoi
très important pourquoi est-ce que
effectivement on a beaucoup de mal à ce
que la population change parce que
jusqu'à aujourd'hui quelqu'un dont la
situation évolue professionnelle
financière qu'est-ce qu'il fait elle
s'en va et donc finalement elle est
remplacée par quelqu'un qui est tout
aussi voir encore un peu plus précaire
pourquoi est-ce que comme vous le dites
on n'arrive pas à faire cette mixité
c'est pas faute d'avoir mis en place un
certain type de logements puisque comme
vous le savez il n'y a pas un logement
social mais des logements sociaux et
suivant les logements que vous
construisez le reste à charge donc le
loyer pour l'habitant n'est pas le même
et donc si on fait des programmes mixtes
sur le papier on peut proposer à
d'autres personnes de venir habiter la
question pourquoi est-ce que ces
personnes ne viennent pas ou si elles
viennent et je peux vous faire un
exemple précis boulevard Wilson à Reims
avec des logements pls 80% de la
population française peut habiter dans
un pls pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne
viennent pas parce que miner par le
trafic de parce qu'ils en ont marre que
leur voiture soit cassée en ont marre
que la boîte aux lettres soient
arrachées ils en ont marre de pas
pouvoir acheter une tranche de jambon
des choses basiques qui quelque part
nous ramènent à se débat précédent qui
n'est donc pas une question d'angélisme
mais une première question qui est
comment assurons-nous la sécurité dans
un quartier deuxième sujet la rénovation
urbaine c'est la bonne occasion de faire
le point avec la famille sur sa
situation quand vous rencontrez une
famille pour lui expliquer qu'on va
réhabiliter son appartement que
peut-être ça se fait avec un
déménagement c'est l'occasion de faire
le point et de discuter avec cette
famille de son évolution parce que la
vraie question c'est pourquoi on trouve
des familles dans lesquelles on a des
enfants en situation d'échec scolaire
sur qui sont là qui ne font rien
pourquoi le père est au chômage depuis
longtemps ce sont tous ces sujets
l'habitat ne peut pas tout c'est évident
dans les quartiers est-ce qu'on a pas un
peu négligé l'humain quand on regarde le
plan Borlo que vous connaissez
on puisse avoir autre chose que de la
discipline une approche pédagogique
différente maintenant la question est
jette dessus je ne peux que la partager
c'est aujourd'hui comment effectivement
alors vous faisiez allusion au plan de
Jean-Louis on peut faire allusion à
l'alarme le l'ouvrage qu'il a commis au
moment de la campagne des
présidentielles l'année dernière on
l'appelle de Grigny avec des sujets
comment est-ce qu'on met des campus des
métiers dans les quartiers parce que les
heures d'insertion de la rue c'est bien
mais ça suffit pas je sais pas parce que
j'habite dans un quartier que je veux
aller dans le bâtiment et comment on
arrive à faire ça je voudrais que vous
nous disiez aussi au fond d'où vient
l'argent parce qu'on entend beaucoup
cette petite musique les milliards qui
se déploie dans les banlieues alors
c'est 24 milliards sur la période
2014-2030 tout n'est pas dépensé 12
milliards plus 12 milliards c'est pas de
l'argent public alors déjà on parle
c'est pas l'argent du contribuable alors
c'est pas tout à fait ça si vous me
permettez le premier plan de rénovation
urbaine qui a commencé dès les années
2005 et qui s'est arrêté en 2015
représente 12 milliards effectivement
c'est 12 milliards
10% vient de ce que l'on appelle
l'argent du 1% logement c'est à dire les
cotisations des entreprises cet argent a
servi à non seulement réhabiliter ou
bien démolir des immeubles faire des
équipements dans les quartiers dont
certains malheureusement viennent de
brûler mais ce qui est important c'est
que cet argent représente 40 000 emplois
dans le bâtiment pendant 10 ans d'une
partie de la population qui vient
d'ailleurs des quartiers représente 4
milliards d'euros de TVA et représentent
6 milliards de cotisations sociales si
c'est pas des fonds perdus ce sont pas
des c'est important de le rappeler
deuxième programme qui est qui vient de
démarrer qui a été dont le financement a
été bouclé l'année dernière par le
premier ministre Jean Castex qui est le
deuxième programme le npnue le nouveau
programme de rénovation urbaine qui lui
va consacrer concerner
453 chantiers dans notre pays 446 ont
démarré au moment où je vous parle je
voudrais qu'on dise un mot sur les
parents parce qu'ils sont sacrément
pointés du y compris au sommet de l'État
appel à la responsabilité d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'il tienne leur gosse ça c'est
ce qu'a dit Eric Dupond-Moretti de
claquer au lit préconise le préfet de
l'Hérault quand on a un gamin de 12 ans
qui descend dans la rue pour caillasser
est-ce que ça vous semble approprié
comme réponse est-ce que les parents
dans ces quartiers là sont
démissionnaires alors on ne va
évidemment pas généraliser on va prendre
plusieurs éléments l'obligation des
parents c'est dans le Code civil jusque
là rien extraordinaire pour ceux qui
sont mariés ils l'entendent quand ils
vont se marier c'est un des articles que
chaque élu lié au moment il célèbre un
mariage une fois qu'on a dit ça on a
dans les quartiers pratiquement 25% des
familles qui sont des familles
monoparentales la plupart du temps des
mamans qui sont celles qui assume seul
et ça déjà c'est extrêmement difficile
elle bosse elles assument leurs enfants
elles sont pas forcément là parce que
comme elles sont parties bosser elles
sont pas forcément moi je pense qu'il ne
faut pas les culpabiliser en même temps
vous avez d'autres parents qui sont des
couples et quand j'entends un père dire
mon fils n'a rien fait à propos des
émeutes il est juste allé se servir à
aller se servir c'est voler et ça il
faut le dire donc là encore il doit y
avoir des réponses sur ce qui est de la
délinquance et derrière il faut
incontestablement réfléchir à la manière
dont on peut aller plus loin sur ces
sujets crise de l'autorité c'est un défi
immense tout à fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il y a des pistes on entend dire qu'il
faut
des peines minimales dès la première
connerie j'entends parler même du de
l'uniforme certains parlent d'un d'un
service militaire volontaire alors moi
je fais partie des gens qui ont
effectivement cité cette notion du SMA
qui existe outre-mer qui permet un
certain nombre de jeunes de pouvoir
découvrir le champ des possibles d'être
considéré Escal qualité de jeûne et
d'envisager une formation ça existe mais
c'est très peu connu en métropole ça
s'appelle le effectivement comme vous
venez de dire le SMV de la même manière
minimum volontaire et militaire
volontaire service militaire volontaire
nous allons et quelque part si vous
voulez il y a aussi les fameuses épites
qui avaient été créées après les émeuts
de 2005 dont l'objectif était de
reprendre parce qu'il faut avoir la
lucidité de se dire pour que pour
certains jeunes on repart sur les
fondamentaux c'est se lever c'est qui
décroche complètement vous avez vu
aujourd'hui très rapidement les débats
partent avec une agressivité je suis
ancien député l'agressivité de
l'hémicycle cet agressivité est partout
et quelque part cet agressivité est
aussi un ferment difficile nous avons
parlé des policiers vous avez à juste
titre parler des pompiers est-ce que
vous trouvez normal que pratiquement un
soir surdule Les policiers doivent aller
aux urgences des hôpitaux parce que les
gens se battent donc on voit bien que là
dessus c'est ce que pour moi vraiment un
sujet majeur qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière le terme d'autorité comment on
arrive à ce qu'il y ait une sorte de
d'accord national parce que finalement
c'est les règles que l'ensemble de la
population accepte de respecter qui nous
permet de faire nation et je pense que
ça c'est le fond du sujet merci beaucoup
Catherine votre reine aurait pu
continuer bien longtemps mais c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis leur
parti pris vont vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
Thomas l'estavel pour l'économie bonsoir
qui va nous parler télétravail attention
c'est pas forcément la panacée
ffte-t-elle de libération qui suit
justement les questions liées à la
politique de la ville mais on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
histoire de jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous qui nous l'a raconté Stéphanie
Despierre bonsoir bonsoir ce soir c'est
arrow sur les insoumis depuis le début
des émeutes s'obstine à ne pas appeler
simplement au calme voici ce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à tweeté ce week-end
les chiens de garde nous ordonnent
d'appeler au calme nous appelons à la
justice alors hier à l'Assemblée la
première ministre a sonné la charge
politique
quand vos députés rejettent tout à fait
au calme vous sortez du champ
républicain quand une de vos députés
affirment que la fin justifie les moyens
vous sortez du champ républicain voilà
et cette attitude des insoumis à
susciter l'incompréhension y compris
dans la nuque chez les partenaires de
gauche et oui Myriam alors que les
plaies causés par les divergences
stratégiques pendant le débat sur les
retraites commençaient à cicatriser
c'est un nouvel accro dans laupes voir
le début d'un fossé les écologistes les
socialistes et les communistes ont tous
appelé au calme et il ne comprennent pas
la position des insoumis les plus
critiques se sont les communistes et
sans surprise leur numéro 1 Fabien
Roussel le meilleur ennemi des insoumis
je me désolidarise totalement des propos
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon de certains de ses
députés qui ont refusé d'appeler au
calme et qui ont légitimé cette violence
en disant c'est normal c'est une révolte
non
écoutez la réplique cinglante de la chef
des députés en soumis
je me rappelle que Monsieur Roussel
était devant l'Assemblée nationale avec
ses mêmes syndicats de police que je
mets en cause aujourd'hui qui disait le
problème de la police c'est la justice
alors que l'Assemblée nationale était en
train
d'examiner un texte justement sur la
question de la justice donc je crois que
je n'ai aucune leçon à recevoir de
Monsieur Roussel et même les divisions
atteignent les socialistes et où ce qui
est notable c'est le changement de ton
d'Olivier Faure le patron du Parti
socialiste il est l'artisan de l'accord
avec la nupesse et l'un de ses plus
grands défenseurs même quand sa tangue
sur l'affaire 4 nain sur les retraites
Olivier Faure cherche toujours une fine
et à relativiser ces divergences pas
cette fois il a eu des mots très durs le
moment actuel est un moment de profond
désaccord on ne peut pas donner le
sentiment d'encourager et d'accepter la
violence alors on connaissait Myriam le
loyal mais libre d'Édouard Philippe côté
macroniste il y a désormais à gauche le
aligné mais pas dans la ligne d'Olivier
Faure et la propension de la France
insoumise à pilonner la loi 19 de 2017
sur la légitime défense des policiers
n'arrangent pas les relations avec les
socialistes et alors à qui profite
toutes ces fractures au sein de la
gauche alors il est trop tôt pour savoir
si
cette divergence vous faites bien la
nupette si le divorce aura lieu mais le
camp présidentiel s'engouffre dans la
brèche bien décidée à utiliser au
maximum ces désaccords l'exécutif
aimerait pouvoir récupérer les voix des
plus modérées de la gauche pour
consolider sa majorité relative alors il
appuie là où ça fait mal et flat
socialiste et écologiste démonstration
d'Elisabeth borne hier aux questions
d'actualité
vous auriez pu comme vos alliés de la
nupesse demandez justice et appeler sans
ambiguïté au retour au calme monsieur le
député Boris Vallaud
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
car vous avez condamné sans ambiguïté
les violences qui ont touché de
nombreuses communes et appelé à la paix
civile à la différence de vos alliés
insoumis
madame la Présidente Cyrielle châtelain
c'est violence vous les avez condamnés
et je veux saluer cette attitude
républicaine qui tranche avec celle de
certains de vos alliés
trois fois en une demi-heure donc alors
obsédé par la France insoumise et les
fractures de la nupestre il ne faudrait
pas toutefois que le gouvernement oublie
d'autres fractures celles profondes
entre une partie de la jeunesse et la
police merci beaucoup d'un tout petit
mot celle qui profite politiquement de
tout ça
Marine Le Pen c'est malheureusement
d'une évidence absolue je crois qu'il
faut être conscient que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens font moi je parle de ma
petite expérience locale l'état de
sidération dans laquelle étaient les
habitants de la ville jeudi matin
laisser peu de place à d'autres
commentaires que celui-là allez on
enchaîne avec vous c'est une question un
peu tabou qui se pose quand même à bas
bruit ces émeutes pourraient-elles
menacer les Jeux olympiques de Paris
alors ce matin le patron de la solideo
la société de livraison des ouvrages
olympiques avaient réuni la presse pour
faire le point sur l'avancée des
chantiers un nom des JO la réunion était
prévue à l'avance sauf que il a commencé
par lister les attaques dont les sites
ont été l'objet et nous a dit là on a
vraiment eu chaud alors trois exemples
tous en scène-saint-denis il y a eu des
cocktails Molotov qui ont été jetés
contre le village olympique il y a eu
une tentative d'intrusion dans le
cluster des médias au Bourget il y a eu
la piscine d'Aubervilliers qui a failli
partir en fumée parce qu'elle était à
côté du fameux dépôt de bus de la RATP
qui lui-même a été incendié voilà
c'était on a eu chaud on a eu chaud mais
plus de peur que de mal oui mais que du
matériel France oui voilà mais l'image
de la France on a quand même pris un
coup évidemment vu le résultat encore
les professionnels du tourisme on dit
que il y avait une flambée des
annulations pour cet été entre 20 et 25%
des séjours annulés à Paris ce week-end
déjà à l'image est très écornée
oui alors le patron d'abord le patron de
l'office de tourisme de Paris a dit
attention le problème c'est pas des
émeutes en soi c'est la répétition et on
a déjà eu quand même les feux de
poubelle pendant la réforme des
retraites etc ça commence à faire
beaucoup et effectivement
Bruno Le Maire craignant de nouveau
voilà que la France souffre de cette
mauvaise image est allée sur CNN il
s'est adressée à l'opinion américaine
pour la rassurer mais aussi pour
relativiser en lui disant écoutez vous
les émeutes vous en avez connu aux
États-Unis et puis à Londres en 2011 un
an avant il y avait eu également des
violences urbaines les JO ce sont passés
malgré tout ça a été c'est pas si c'est
très rassurant si chacun a ses émotes
au-delà de ces discours est-ce que les
autorités sont fébril on les sent quand
même fébrile il y a deux raisons il y a
une raison juridique c'est pas très
connue mais dans le contrat qui lit
Paris la ville haute au CIO le Comité
international olympique il y a une
clause de résiliation quand même et vous
la lire elle dit que le CIO pourrait
[Musique]
et moi j'ai tendance à penser même si je
suis à Libération j'ai tendance à
prendre le parti dédié l'allemand en
disant bon ok Paris est une fête voilà
et mingway etc les JO c'est une fête
mais l'angoisse qu'il se passe quelque
chose ne risque-t-elle pas de tout
gâcher Catherine votre inquiète c'est
très inquiétant parce que quand on fait
la série finalement
gilet jaune les manifestations moments
des retraites les quartiers aujourd'hui
et on sait que la ville haute est bien
sûr Paris mais qui a également d'autres
territoires en France qui sont concernés
et très concrètement ce qui est ce qui
nous interpelle à très court terme mais
vous l'avez fort bien rappelé c'est que
le tourisme reprenait de façon
absolument remarquable après on vient
quand même de s'offrir la parenthèse
covid qui avait été très compliqué pour
les professionnels il redémarrait une
saison tout à fait intéressante
s'annonçait et là effectivement les
chiffres d'annulation vont donner sont
particulièrement préoccupants donc oui
c'est préoccupant allez on termine au
patchages pardonnez-moi Thomas Lestavel
vous vouliez nous parler du télétravail
c'est vrai que pendant les vacances
scolaires on est bien contents de
pouvoir rester à la maison et garder un
oeil sur les enfants mais vous n'êtes
pas dithyrambique vous sur des
télétravail alors effectivement Myriam
si on rembobine un peu donc quand on a
pandémie c'était déclenché les gens ont
dû se confiné on a d'abord cru à la
catastrophe on s'est dit les entreprises
n'arriveront pas à fonctionner avec des
effectifs éclater un peu partout et puis
la bonne surprise bah dans la plupart
des cas ça marchait et puis on a
commencé à lire un peu partout que les
travailleurs étaient plus productifs
quand ils bossait chez eux pourquoi on
se concentre mieux on économise du temps
de transport on est moins fatigué on est
plus heureux et donc on est plus
productif visio boulot dodo mais en fait
même après le pic de la pandémie des
boîtes comme méta ou même en France
telantis donc PSA ont encouragé leurs
salariés à déserter les bureaux et en
fait semis du télétravail il est en
train de tomber et d'ailleurs les géants
du web Apple Google et meta viennent
d'imposer trois jours de présence au
bureau donc c'est un voltage pourquoi
précisément alors il y a des nouveaux
papiers de recherche qui sont venus
casser cette idée qu'on serait plus
productif chez soi qu'au bureau et le
cuisine britannique vie économiste a
compilé ses travaux et c'est assez
éclairant alors un exemple on a une
étude de deux chercheurs du MIT sur des
employés de bureau basé en Inde ce qui
travaille à distance sont 18% moins
productifs à l'heure que ceux qui
bossent au bureau ou autre étude de
trois universitaires qui ont observé un
écart du même ordre de 19% au sein d'un
groupe informatique en Asie et même
Myriam les joueurs d'échec seraient
apparemment meilleur en présentiel quand
les alors ça c'est pour le constat
l'observe mais comment on l'explique
alors au bureau en fait c'est simple
c'est que quand on en télétravail la
collaboration est moins fluide malgré
tout si je suis à distance et que j'ai
une remarque ou une question un peu bête
qui vient à l'esprit je me tourne vers
ma voisine je lui pose on appelle ça le
small talk c'est voilà des discussions
un peu futile parfois mais qui créent du
lien à la maison je peux utiliser le
chat ou des outils comme ça mais c'est
moins spontané j'ai peut-être parfois me
censurer et puis tout simplement avoir
la flemme d'écrire les interactions sont
pas exactement de même nature des
chercheurs d'Harvard ont révélé que les
feedbacks entre collègues donc les
retours entre collègues sur leurs
performances entre guillemets diminue
quand chacun travaille chez soi or le
feedback c'est quand même un outil de
performance ou d'amélioration l'essence
de brainstorming pareil ça marche moins
bien on perd en créativité quand chacun
est derrière son ordi et enfin il faut
pas négliger un aspect et ici en échelle
LCP c'est la politique si vous voulez
monter dans la hiérarchie d'une boîte il
faut vous mettre en avant il faut vous
créer des alliés tout simplement et pour
ça rester derrière son écran ça va pas
suffire il va falloir continuer à aller
au bureau le bon vieux métro boulot
dedans merci rien ne vaut le contact
physique n'est-ce pas on parlait de
cohésion c'est un exemple de cohésion
que de se retrouver avant et après merci
beaucoup Catherine merci d'être venu sur
le plateau de SCP merci à vous les
affranchis à demain Stéphanie très belle
soirée sur LCP bien évidemment
[Musique]